my friends just for less Montreal why
excited you guys could be here
especially if that weird 70s sitcom
music turn it out with how's your
weekend been so far my week I've been
here since Monday and I've come French
now I'm pretty I don't think that's how
that works I don't think this could ever
be friends I'm on kids culture night
basically doing like a fur trapper that
may I say that this is total like some
real glass houses [ __ ] here okay the guy
made Elizabeth Smart disappears get to
go throw bed no I every time I come here
like what happens is that in this town
which you guys know they say bonjour
before they say hello yeah I walk into a
store like I walkthroughs for the other
day and a lady was looking down and she
said bonjour and then she looked up and
looked and she goes oh hello
did you know right away you said I was
with you and you called like we saw a
Chinese woman and he goes Bonjour settle
down shot a hole 0 is fine was it was
like the Canadian thing yeah I'm like
Bonjour what the [ __ ] it was crazy I was
here a couple years ago and I had
nothing to do during the day and super
sex was still around i guess they closed
that down which I really sad about don't
be sad like it's the Louvre or something
that super-sized closing it as Dan's
military coming home to their dog that
is easily get said about hi but I
another dealer today so I went up there
at like noon and i went with super sex
oh my god I got a lap dance in the
middle of the day and then like after
our show the other night it was me
Michael che and Paul verzi we were
watching we doing right oh let's go to
the strip club and we start walking down
the street and they're like let's go to
this one I was super sex with my father
gonna know hopefully no one recognizes
me from earlier you don't want to be
there and then we get in there and I
swear to god we open that we enter to
the road and the stripper who gave me
the lap dance church mean because damn
gave me [ __ ] like I was a regular it was
cheers but food it's like it I can tell
she advanced I know that Kim the only
time that's happened no no this is a
game not get to [ __ ] I mean way worse he
stole our Doritos beauty care well I was
never the pod guess we started the
podcast a couple years ago when we
started the pub dan st. germain well
let's also do this really quickly you
tell me you might not be familiar with
the podcast it's called my dumb friends
that's cause we're friends and we're
kind of dummies also it's me we have
guess you'll just in case you didn't
know what the image is ready right
exactly we we have friends on to come on
and talk about the dumbest [ __ ] they've
ever done you up there like right so
that's what we're gonna be doing today
as well as our own [ __ ] in the
beginning right that's pretty much what
it is they're so go ahead explain that
kind of angry you put up please
understand what we're talking before we
do this I need to connect to a human
this is our producer Tom Lewis yeah give
every time nipples have been
conspicuously a rectal very what was
that why is it was a lonely GI Joe
you have your nipples are unnecessarily
hard rings I don't you're excited about
the strip club so you took a female
bodybuilder oh yeah sweet you remind me
of but anyway at least heard his podcast
a couple years ago when we started it
was like 2012 and I had just gotten out
of rehab and at that time your statuses
were so know that I brought up my god
Sean oh my oh my god we just got out of
reach I gotta rehab that time and he
broke because yeah did your facebook
sense is that whole year were the most
depressing train wrecks Ted I'm like
[ __ ] ever write something you regret
on facebook yeah he did that for three
months trip how they get work that bad
and then I went through these a week ago
and they're even worse than their as
they are so brutal do you see this yeah
that's before these young crowd work for
a pot
they can hear him smiling it was smiling
I can't but to do this we're so excited
to have him on the podcast yes comes
he's gonna help [ __ ] on these with us I
can't believe we got it i'm super
excited yes everybody please welcome Jim
Norton everybody know is here he comes
thank you so much for doing this Jim let
him sit down and takes my Johnny Cash
you very much for having me yeah thank
you for doing this man really I'm a hard
guy to get all you have to do is say
what are you doing you you were actually
in the conference room how was your
festival going so far I came in
yesterday it was ok kool yeah I did once
out last night so I'm trying to work out
something for a gallon and it wasn't I
did too much like Trump material it's
very like us centric which the crowd let
me know we're not interested
I i did i did my cell last nite nite
Trump stuff up front and then I like
their what you can't do that much but
it's my opener and I look back yeah
don't give a [ __ ] right quick mention or
two or they get you know but people
haven't been following it as closely
here you know nobody wants to hear about
Ben Carson's diction cool so please help
us really quickly [ __ ] on this is like a
show this is like seriously at night
like this is seriously a nightmare i go
went through these and I'm swear to God
I wrote all these sincerely this isn't
like this first one I we want to start
out with I was volunteering for New York
care it's just that i wrote volunteering
at an after school program for new york
cares but all the kids don't want to
hang out with me okay that's also Jared
Fogle's post I remember the only one who
hung out he was a kid with a hip problem
get away we started with the Saanich
want everybody but yeah and then and
then there is comment somebody wrote
don't take it personally and then my
sister wrote take it
family law all right was a time hold on
for a second all right whatever we
already did it thanks a lot okay I then
I went through my real pretentious like
phase where I literally wrote a serious
status update about both Occupy Wall
Street and mala and it's one of like I
thought I was basically you I'm gonna
make you read the back because it's so
bad it's really bad uh-uh this is like
painful but love Nicholas Kristof
article about Malala I can't even say
the last name he knew I the spelling you
google dis billion she's the brave young
14 year old girl who is shot by Taliban
sympathizers for advocating women's
education rights in Pakistan although
our country pours money into the
pakistan defence but by the way I'm just
plagiarizing whatever I like
that article easy drunk on speed to help
out Malala and other humans rights
groups fighting for education you can go
to developments in literacy and the
citizens foundation to donate with a
donation link right there no likes by
the way dan management balala unlikeable
would you do that like you would try to
help people it was just like I kind of
hitting on her for when she turned 18
wasn't she shot didn't you tell us you
know she a lot that was a big issue to
rabbit I'm sure after she read that
she's like can you shoot me again will
your little melodramatic my god and then
at the end of this when I just real
press I wrote they make me proud to be
an American after occupy wait what the
like that's so painful that no one's
even reacting or they're just not
reactive it's so fun that you were sober
during I made you proud to be American
Occupy Wall Street that's a nice
sentiment yeah thanks Jim that's
uncomfortable all right so are the next
one this is what I I just wrote man
slavery was really shitty it was totally
[ __ ] up we did then i went from like
trying to be really
really profound to just like this is
like like a bro bro that thinks he's
like really the pellet gun that's true
it's a statement I wish no one can argue
with you slavery was really shitty gotta
go play them across right no it's also
[ __ ] up Oh God did anyone comes down
that sensitive also you guys see that I
can do the next one so you know look at
the juxtaposition who runs the show at
lesion bar on Saturday I'm doing it and
forget what it starts forget who runs it
so in a couple weeks you went to slavery
is horrible to can I get booked on your
board oh my god I that's like a step
above me just get like going outside on
a street corner being like hey where do
I go the next one trying to fight a
[ __ ] Bible in the city angriest
anybody search for a bug yeah you like
to preacher from Midnight Cowboy but
strong
one day I think we had all this what is
this a wife one more which is I owe
everything to other comics who helped me
out which I tried to be nice comment 1
comment for this which was fun that's me
you instill confidence and then Thomas
giving me [ __ ] but this is the kind of
[ __ ] that Tom posts here what is it the
cool this is Tom's dog likes butter
socks like butter hashtag flowers egbert
here check pittsfield panic dog hashtag
dogs from Instagram hashtag butter
hashtags I've been less offended by Isis
coats horrible who likes dogs
she's cute
yeah what do you oh my god that for me
is scarier that's like something is
really wrong at home when you start when
you add in your 40s hell do you talk
like a Stepford wife yeah I to like fix
the problem i miss socks right now oh my
god after the socks nah it's fine he's
listen yeah you jumped in front of a
[ __ ] trouble you read dance at
accenture socks is a she okay we forgot
about that no how about Jim if you
burberry what was you at your worst ever
like where you like so embarrassed the
[ __ ] you wrote it oh I was I went to
read how when I was seventeen years it
was one of those you know kind of fake
suicide attempts and I was I wrote a
poem and Rehab I really should have my
writing hand beaten with a hammer I
wrote a poem years later wrote a book
and I went over the palm and I corrected
it and it just really criticize myself
now that I'm sober what a douche bag I
was yeah everyone just bellow dramatic
poem about alcohol I don't know the
title the bone no I didn't have a title
I left it anonymously somewhere
everybody in the rehab was talking about
the pulp did it but I would swell with a
tribe
and then by the time I confess that was
me who wrote it nobody gave a [ __ ] on to
somebody like some new guy came in and
detox by screaming on top of a pulpit
about that poem we're all right yeah
humiliating oh my god that was a rehab
there was a guy because everyone
believed at different point and everyone
would make a speech and then this kid
who was like it is like like 23 he's
like he's like all right guys we're all
gonna make it we're gonna do we're gonna
get through this little wild laughing
and we're like yeah he OD like to eat
cheese I'm the only one who thought that
was funny
lemons to lemonade he had two good weeks
in there he almost did it yes tended to
get a Santa's tipster I drank in the
rehab but drank my roommate Duane I was
17 years time sweets to go out to these
12 step meetings and my roommate snuck
out and bought himself a pint of wine
and me a half pint of vodka and Harvey
who would go let's go Harvey would go to
meetings with us he was a weird guy
maybe laughs but he was sick hottie like
you just go funny guy isn't Michael
Winslow and we drank in the rehab and
yeah they called us out on it but I lied
so I didn't have to go to a long-term
facility airs my show this yeah Iscariot
that was scary sure you yep you know
you've been so that's why I'm here dude
yeah the whole adult life so well that
point just thank you much doesn't mean a
room meeting anyway it certainly does
it's got the same enthusiasm just
scattered people wishing they were not
drinking
it feels like everybody relapse the
night before and it's got to be old hat
to you like you have you still out you
feel like you want to drink or anything
but you're not even comfortable and yeah
I'm never too comfortable I just know
that I have to be vigilant but I'm very
lucky I sighs well I [ __ ] up the whole
careers unfortunate that's great yeah
who's gonna carry a message i mean i
think that's what's important i remember
one day to rehab they just bought us
brought us in a room and played James
Taylor's fire and rain until we cried
they language like they were trying to
fear frantically tries you into the
woman that it's like you can't leave do
you here for these you crying more about
Suzanne and those flying machines on the
ground I hate to see a rowing machine
well you know who told me that that saw
a guy named Wayne on the way to he's
down he's dead now he overdosed he was
on a water out of a meeting he's like
he's smoking and he was fast and he was
psychotic he always said that that white
[ __ ] that matter depressives get in the
corner of their mouths when they take
medication I mean he was like this songs
about his girlfriend suzanne she died i
want to see him the whole story about
Wayne
I certainly want again is X to Z that's
like I like my thing is I'll say stuff
about people in rehab but I won't say
like 12 steps like if I made a meeting
but you want I think that's the one
thing I want to talk about some of the
[ __ ] I've seen in there so bad but you
really can't can't yeah and it's just
it's the worst thing in the world
because you're just like presented with
three premises every [ __ ] a because
what I'm doing a bit about this guy's
even they just beat the [ __ ] out of you
like yeah private Pyle and [ __ ] full
metal jacket you know I never i always
keep people's you know I don't tell you
I not tell want to sometimes but you
just can't you can't do it one thing
I'll say about me is that I was a timer
at a 12th which is the weirdest job
effort so you you betta bloomer you have
to time people to keep them from going
over time and a share so like somebody
would be like so there I was on the
Jersey State turnpike selling my last
tow for heroin that I'm like n time back
next week that's the way it should be
store it faster sit with you my father
would read any well I hope got a rape
you all for this week great instead of
you saying time you just played Oscar
music oh my god dude was like a weaver
rehabbing the shipping fee like you
think it's funny there you come out
you're like yeah and then he's a [ __ ]
turned out he died and it feels like you
[ __ ] monster there I go it's funny
sick sense of humor when you're ready
you hear people saying such horrible
things and you know when you hear enough
people say horrible things it doesn't
become surprising anymore it's like she
sensitizes you yeah favor links to it I
remember one time we were at the rehab
and and this uh this girl like they
drove this girl their mom I guess
throughout this girl her 20s she had
tell her it was a rehab yeah and she got
out of that she got out of the car
they'd tell her and she's like okay
here's the rehab just like [ __ ] you then
starts running again I gun we all cheer
for shoots right
run Forrest run Jersey get the
Pennsylvania here two days later she's
like McMurphy with the five Scarn the
moms like I love you the fewer like Chen
that [ __ ] doesn't understand oh she
threw a big sink through the window and
she's chief jail thank you so much for
doing this am I getting the boot off it
we want you to stay for the whole thing
we've you want to talk Borg we just want
to also give you the opportunity to
leave a few this is the saddest way on a
day like I want you to say but please
I'm not going Oh awesome we have some
little confidence but like other
probably want to leave right now have
you like this is just a perk wee boy yes
there's a lot of people to pilot against
but have you have like one significant
bomb when you started out because I've
only known you as a killer you know it
like cuz i start comedy you heard
crushing you know so but like when you
started at did you have any like cuz i
remember when i started out i tried to
go in a mitch hedberg basically rip off
or I just like sure yeah we didn't like
Danny's got puppets that he used on
stage it was just one night marriage
it's only marginally improved let's be
honest yeah well real quick by my worst
bombed i remember was Ron's knew this
guy Bob Leavy who's a comic I really
looked up to his hosting at rascal south
and he brought me on and I wound up
bombing horribly and it was such a
dramatic Xperia I'm gonna drive home
crying and I'm like I'm a became my
dream was ruined and I'm like I think
the next night I'm like okay [ __ ] I'm
gonna go onstage and try it again but
then I think Desert Storm the first
desert storm broke out this like 1990
and but I knew would never hurt that bad
again abad bombed a lot worse and i
bombed it more critical times but it's
never been that bad that was yeah yeah
it's stuck with you the long as that was
gonna stuff it was it was yours mine was
where I would like I was six months in
and I was at in the West Village and I
heard I literally you know what saying
where I'm bombing so bad and it's so
quiet that you hear a guy say to his
friend I'm heckling he just says to his
friend he goes this guy's very good
I hear that every show I did my eternal
giving yes you I mean all together you'd
like to hang out we love that I always
hang you yes thank you Jim yeah next
dish let's bring up our next guest you
know her from 24 you guys know what she
is pigs gotta from Marilyn Ross copy
hello very well thank you so sure do
with it me the word in every right yeah
he's the Northland thanks Jim don't
leave now he's gonna switch ridiculous
right is which Marilyn thank you for
doing this thank you so I feel like oh
it's it that would be a little cigarette
I'll Mary's here [ __ ] this
marsa nation how do you Marilyn pretty
good I was professional going so far
hello I've been here whole week well ya
doing the pre festival so it was super
quiet so I had a lot of days where it
was a lot of french-speaking and yeah be
alone go to that food court and just eat
food and take pictures of myself
surrounded by people not talking to some
of the street performers I'm like every
weirder if you were in a pedophile you
know you're like clowns from a nightmare
yeah these bobblehead [ __ ]
walking around like a baby this is it
they would I want more global warming
now yeah there was a street guy trying
to street before with the other day his
whole Act I don't of you guys saw this
it was him but it was a Barcalounger and
a TV and he was watching golf videos on
a TV and he just had a golf club
watching it like he was watching it this
living room he's like that come on but
he was staying in friendly walking by
and I like what the [ __ ] you doing is
worth it was kind of cool [ __ ] she's
like David Lynch may CJ spray pushed
away off I saw the weird baby in a did
you see that Oh
you know they fake baby I don't know
what bubble girl girl a bubble bowl that
was rolling on the face or two oh yeah
that was kind of cool did anybody see
the guy who was pretending to be blind
that was his living improv my gosh
pretending what is it what is that what
is it what's the advantage and I've
beside you get to grab tits and go
yeah I don't even know why i would say
that lady classy lady right though you
meant to you definitely wrote I don't
see that concern for the blind guy that
was appointed when I feel like it when I
know it's a bit here def sometimes I've
in a relationship you like tripping mr.
gently fingering someone sorry oh jeez
how'd you get creepier than all the
absences I saw you in the elevator like
a half an hour ago hope I don't know
what I was generally figure though I
tell you in that any of your life i
don't know if i have anything crazy or
die little and then she just you just
did a story i'm like yeah that's [ __ ]
insane of course that's something you
should talk about now every pub tell
someone hey you're that joking Harry
I'm like the white diabetic fire now I'm
just [ __ ] sweating blue cheese right
now huh I was it started about it's just
a thing I mean I'll get into it I just
it's something that happened that's not
even really it is is it I mean here's
the thing I'm here doing comedy and tips
let's don't sound something about to see
something really son like beginning a
therapy session this is my a meeting
yeah I'm not good enough to have been in
rehab like you gentlemen I wish but I
think comedy is my rehab but people
recognize me from 24 and then I can have
a one-woman show that i'm doing and i'll
say you know I was on 24 then people
would be like yeah cuz then I'll tell
some terrible thing that happened all
the way I was I went to the Golden
Globes and I show a slide of me at the
Golden Globes and everyone's like a
pretty girl in a dress tell a story of
like how shitty it was and how i sat at
a table alone drink and I only got one
ticket and then I ran into Cheryl they
give you tickets yeah I give you
trinkets for a second until you know
certainly the Uni drink tickets that's
awesome you don't get a plus one so I
got sent at a table by myself and just
waited for everyone to show up and then
I look at the placards and they weren't
even from the show I was on like from
the sitcom ugly betty and not just the
cast of what's happening the desert
you'd only need to leave legroom for
Mabel King down to the bar cuz you can
you know and then Sheryl Crow was there
and I was like oh I know her and I then
I realized I didn't know her but I was
already upon her and I yelled I feel so
alone you didn't know her before that
now firstly you said of Sheryl Crow is I
feel civil yeah what you think every day
is a winding it
I said all I want to do to have some fun
yeah so that's my comedy act is already
I feel like I'm bursting the bubble of
things that people are excited about and
then on top of that I talk about my
husband being a rebound and we got
pregnant by accident and then he you
know was like me it's me then we can to
have that beautiful romantic
conversation of just two people who
barely know each other and decide have a
baby together you know so I'm pregnant
and I kind of won't have the baby that's
me could you take the test again really
said that you know I feel like I'm
getting more real in my comedy right
that's the best stuff like i am telling
the truth but also i just did a canadian
TV spot this is my a meeting by the way
I just get it all and my son just turned
eight and so like he gets it all you
know what I mean like he would he looked
on my iPhone memos and he listened and
he's like mommy shouldn't say those
words what you here buddy like what did
you hear you know and I I feel like I'm
getting better at comedy but I'm also
may be revealing stuff about my family
you're ruining his life
to worry Martin did our show and she's a
writer on conscious hilarious and she
brought her kid and had him wear
headphones [ __ ] about his father and he
goes mommy I can hear you turn the
volume pause for a second oh my god i
had a sly on my show where and this is
just it is it comic is just a dumb side
bed were like kind of a giggle but i
just say you know we got married in
planet hollywood and yeah we had a good
Mary to play but oh yeah very romantic
they closed that ghazi curtain between
the casino in the chapel we got as far
as she we could spring for a hard rock
yeah Hollywood but our Catholic nanny
was praying and in my show I go you know
hopefully she was apologizing to Jesus
for everything we've ever done it's just
a thought you know side and that a
picture of Jesus comes up but he has
raised really pretty eye brows I'm like
I'm sorry Jesus and it's just a dumb
moment but my son was like why do you
you know why do you have a picture of
Jesus in your comedy show and I sure and
I tried to explain to him and I said to
his face I go I know I'm perfect
care of you and you look at me and I do
everything right it's a comedy character
she does everything wrong to apologize
for geez I know that's hard for you to
believe you know man he's talking about
the bad words and why would you you know
then it was a side story about he was
like yeah I don't believe in religion
mom he's like I'm not a churchy guy I
think sure I think church is a waste of
time I'm like oh my god what have I done
to this kid and then no after he
listened to your standup so I'm
explaining to him that the character I
play yeah she [ __ ] up all the time I
mean of me I'm awesome but mom that's
you you're writing your company I know
so this whole weekend I just call them
by their names you don't bother making
up a fake name for my son or whatever
anyway all that to say now the story
that I've said you out there which is
it's whatever it happened this is a
relationship it sounds like it'd be any
of a true detective after the firefight
it's just a bet it's all of my things
that I've done that I'm embarrassed with
probably relationships that I've thrown
myself into and they're just [ __ ] up
so this guy that I was really into we
had been together for a while I walked
in on him he was in the in our bed
having sex with himself
black till dessert I know that's the
story that I was like I can't you have
to say that racist they're like black
police but here's what I did I open the
door and then I was like as if I'll
leave you two alone after that it was a
while we just never want to say it was
another eight months to a year knowing
it and going around everyday life and
acting as if you see there's all that
we're never so that the thing about
stuff like that is it's shocking and
you're not but the real stuff that sucks
is like that why would you do that
without me you know yeah it's happening
it's just like oh I know I could be your
black dildo I did you find in the
dishwasher
worse cascade you know he's keep where's
he keeping it it's like his special
friend violation of my position was he
and when he was using was he on his back
or his hands and knees or was he
squatting it was a weird kind of half
squat like trying to be comfortable i'm
laying in bed but i'm sort of squatting
oh yeah yeah it was good core workout he
was using a squatty potty quality was
good the whole thing to thank you for me
to get it a casual and then just be like
okay something that's going on that's
[ __ ] oh my god and you guys dated
after that he walked in and then when he
saw you later he was like hey want to
get some pizza like how that's how big
of a that's a big dildo in the room so
how do you deal with that after a
relationship like you just never
mentioned it you never mentioned it and
then it wasn't until I was in such
denial about it I think that's part of
the story too is I I act like I'm you
know outwardly like I get it you know
I'm involved but when stuff like that
really happens it's kind of a violation
of an intimacy that well I guess an
inter see that wasn't really there
different kind of violations with all
kinds of violations I was here that's
all I would have talked about with you
forever
so what you say person
yeah she would have just taken all the
locks off the doors feel like that poem
in rehab you and bring up to the fact
that it weeks ago Jim was funny would
like when you hook up a so the first
time a girl brought like a vibrator a
big vibrator in bed with me oh my god
that's kind of insulting but now I love
it now I'm like oh god I have to put in
like a color of the work yeah I can just
sit there we get something up yeah yeah
the whole story points at me not our
inability that we're not really talking
about what's happening right between us
yeah you like me here we've said to you
before he did it yeah yeah I'm gonna do
this would you've been like totally way
cooler with it well you were pretty cool
with anybody now I would've second
Romaniacs person I mean the add more
that's funny but we were they so funny
because you're more like it was the more
him not telling you but I want you to
tell me everything and he didn't tell
you that's the more violation than just
a jarring seen of him doing it right
yeah it is tricky to bring stuff up I'm
like you said you don't you weren't sure
about the vibrator and then it and they
were like dancers great it's hard to ask
your girlfriend to put a black dildo in
your ass because you throw in
abdul-jabbar Jersey on
actually one of the dream team well I
think it's time for your third guest up
right let's do it we're so excited about
this guy you know from The Daily Show
Roy Wood jr. really thanks for doing
this man thank you man good times yeah
good to see you buddy yeah these dildos
on yourself way weird now go through
when I wipe my ass one baby steps pretty
much the same thing her boyfriend went
through that's I don't think that's a
finish yet the Pope for my ass but only
if I'm trying to wipe shoe that have to
correct you on your own podcast
Jim we though how'd your principal go
man he have fun man she went out to the
party last night variety but was the
variety partner the frontier guy party
how was that you get loaded drank more
than up plan yeah yeah have that cadence
right now somebody I don't have [ __ ]
drink till 5am bounce back I don't
anymore I don't have it I used to like
now I have to like scheduled three days
of recovery beneficially picture I need
four days off you took yourself out of
the game get tired your website I said
you do get tired of bailing I am I'm 38
man I get super tight yeah I last until
like last night I went I was there for
an hour and I left I was like I just
can't do it like this is a beautiful
city I'm just like I'm old enough now to
like the thing about Airbnb that I like
is that you get to experience a city
like a regular citizen level yeah yeah
we're like this hotel and food truck
it's not like this every day in Montreal
I'll leave all those greatest food
trucks everywhere there was somebody
singing da summer every morning
it's like comedy Narnia just here like
this is amazing comeback your we're
gonna go this is literally dressed for
it to wedding day I can't trust that I
would rather be standing right everybody
in the edge of town some other yeah not
murder death get killed like I don't say
the hood but i would like to really
regular spot don't worry under if that's
the real the anyway first you told me
that you ain't putting yourself in like
weird like really awkward situations it
feels like you're dangerous situations
yeah great stuff this a little more
exciting that way about to get murdered
every minute of every day we did we did
a show if you want to talk about bad
bombs ya know if I can top germs but we
used to do shows I'm from Birmingham and
down south you get onstage wherever you
can cuz it's not 12 comedy clubs with
open mic so every week you drive four
hours to go do five minutes or whatever
yeah we would do shows for dope boys and
like drug dealers down south what they
would do like if the cops bust you and
they took your weed and they took your
coke and they took your money and you
need startup money to get back in the
game yeah you hold a comedy show
brilliant strategy that's how I don't
boys will I put on like a rap show
comedy show and you presale the tickets
you take the pre-sale money you buy key
you take the kilo you chop it up you
sell it and by the time the show happens
you pay your talent from the money you
made from the kilo you bought from the
price watch this is back rolling again
even that's illegal how does it work on
taxes but it only works if you sell the
kilo before the show so we got there and
they hadn't sold the kilo yet it's also
a Kickstarter but way shittier I think
we better and so we're doing a show for
these dope boys and it's dope boy
audience and say you already know you're
not getting paid because they don't have
your money and it was like the hardest
bomb but I can't test the crowd out
because those are his customers you know
like sometimes if your bomb and you just
want to just go full meltdown and just
[ __ ] you people you don't know [ __ ] you
soon yeah I just sit there and take it
you know apologize to them
up there how you didn't get paid to
their credit they offered to pay us in
part ya know if you aren't [ __ ] get a
[ __ ] quarter ounce or some [ __ ]
that's like Scarface bees punch line one
free bit of a helicopter with me to
believe all marvelous gotcha please
never break this up any one of these
shows up for no not that I know those
guys are still going strong the speed is
still don't have made this trailer with
them the old brother yes I'm sure some
people got shot there's like generation
it goes to generation after generation
let's man up come on that's like that's
like speeding that he leaves the kids
are the guys that did it back of the day
they're gonna do it next probably
probably cuz they even by the seller in
New York City there's drug dealers that
walk up and down macdougal street and
they asked if you want weed coke
whatever it is yeah and somebody told me
that's the son of the guy who used to do
it a few years ago no family man that's
horrifying i remember i bought coke once
in washington square park and i was i
was about to go there and i was talking
to my friend Nick and I'm like art all
right we're not gonna let's go get this
let's get this blow and then he's like
where we meeting them like Washington
Square Park you know the least shady
place to buy drew
and then I'm like I'm like don't worry
it'll be cool to be cool yeah I just
don't want to draw attention to
ourselves like don't worry to be cool
and we get to watch the square park and
the drug dealer is my friend Jesse oh
[ __ ] this park in a matrix leather
jacket and leather gloves like in the
middle it looks like just me Michael
Douglas and black green like what
Michael Phelps was to swimming he was he
driving of that you were telling me you
almost got arrested dude eyes there's
been so many different weird moments in
my life i speaking to that point yeah
the we went to the shady spot so i went
to college in tallahassee florida in it
and tie i said they have a ghetto but
it's not as huge it's like an
eight-block radius called french town
has the worst get on internet so i have
roommates in college and like I live
with the first we were the first group
of my circle of friends to live off
campus so all our friends who lived on
campus our house became social central
and so guys will go to French town and
pick up hookers and bring them back to
our house and bang them in whoever
whoever wasn't there your room just got
[ __ ] in so come home from work at
golden corral
and I always had my watching all my [ __ ]
out on the dresser and whoever was in my
robe whoever's in my room they stole my
class ring and so at the time that's
like your main piece of joys of a
[ __ ] four hundred dollar range rover
75 pounds yeah so we ended up in
frenchtown circling the block looking
for a stripper so that we could get my
[ __ ] class ring done this trip she
goes to the phone like no woman is on
the corner and going hey baby you just
want [ __ ] strip team you would have
updated why this class rank in search of
the block three or four times and we see
here we pop out the car we walk up the
block it's five of us he's wearing the
class ring she left it
[ __ ] camp comes up the block any it's
the coldest [ __ ] I've ever heard let's
deal with the dead in the face he goes
young ones I don't know what you came
here looking for but when I circled is a
block on the show give it to you but and
he just drove off on just like let's
[ __ ] go man yeah jeez you guys wait
around you're like oh he's bringing a
story yeah it's a character to Stephen
King movie like hairs on the back of my
leg and I've had gun to pull on me
before but like the legitimacy uh I'm
going to kill you about the [ __ ] hey
you didn't tell me therefore she stole
Eric no there's nothing to discuss this
dude is just decided I'm going to murder
you in the time it takes to circle the
block so give you a heads up 18 what do
you even do yeah yeah yeah just roll up
in murder eighty-year-old 42 year old
pit lane lucious that's like that's
probably one of the scariest make like
that make go [ __ ] toes you guys if I got
here by this because dan told me like
the double points of the story yes Sean
ohh Sean told me is like I'm not nervous
about these diverse people are gonna
have story that I told him this is like
Oh we'll be fine I believe in ghosts so
I should start with that didn't creep
you guys out well my dad died my dad
died when I was 16 at the time my
parents didn't sleep in the same bed
room my dad slept downstairs here like
hip surgery had a cane or whatever yeah
and in the mornings you could always
hear my dad walking across the Florida
dude whatever so as they died for like a
[ __ ] month and a half I can still
hear him getting up getting ready for
[ __ ] work which number one gives me
fear of what the afterlife is
tonight
I meant this lady I didn't know she was
a widow at the time and what kind of we
were going out or whatever and yeah they
get over to her house and I did she had
kids and I see a picture of like her
just dude the two kids and I see
pictures of do it all over the house I'm
like who the [ __ ] is this dude oh he's
dead baby that's my husband all right
fine and we have sex and while we're
having sex I know how [ __ ] hurt
there's a lot crazy while we're having
sex I just hear something like the faint
voices go [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh yeah so the next morning and we screw
again in the morning and then I here
[ __ ] stop believin I know what was your
house is it was insane Keith cuz she
just yeah who told you that I was like I
just I never I never talked to her why
wouldn't you Keith already knew it was
it was this creepy [ __ ] [ __ ] blocking
ghost be great if you woke up in your
class ring was on the night
getting back in he was like with my
blessing different kind of pitter-patter
pickle glad those shirts are key finds
like a ghost lady he's like I got it I
got a [ __ ] you can [ __ ] her again find
him like a chupacabra mystical thing
well guys thank you so much for doing
this thank you about four against
everybody let them hear we usually close
we were using close every episode tom
has had by all accounts a horrific life
instead of like a bit ly in keeping with
the theme of ghost is haunting realistic
this is Tom haunting realization every
week he tells a story from his life and
it makes us grateful that we're not him
thank you he's just stay at home dad and
in the wilderness so tell you a story
now what's hit the music guys so
mr. there's a few years ago my elder
elderly neighbor burst into my house
like which caused problems in the past
she was named it at the feet shoes I'm
just our house and you know it's like I
would be in various stages of undress
sometimes or whatever but she she came
she comes Bob fell down Bob fell down I
need your help her husband grabbed her
elderly husband Bob fell down you need
you need to come over you need to come
over so I go over to their house and
well this is good thanks for having a
real moment Bob's like 90 ok in an old
guy and about 2 250 pounds that's my
sides by the way and he had fallen down
in the shower that's where he had fallen
down in a shower and he's English in
their kind of MOA realize you know I
didn't help him that if the fire
department came they would cut a hole in
the wall to get him out like it would
have destroyed their house to get him
out so I go ok and you know when your
night it's balls everywhere I mean just
I will never wear boxers again gotta
keep it I mean they were it was just
what is that the monster from
cloverfield this it was just their low
and so he's in the shower he's lying
there you know and what happens to your
body i mean it's just it was a whole
revelation of that and so i get over him
to pick him up you know he's like slick
with soap sorry my name is again so
erect I've never seen him a ring before
this it's okay Montreal so he brings out
the big gun that's Ana Ken doll yeah I
you know and you know he had a back
injury that's why I was down in there
and that one of those these stool things
to sit on in there and that's what he
had fallen off if so I like push like
I'm picking him up and he's like oh you
know kind of clawing at it and you know
I think we both farted you know like
no miss Sweeney's like sliding out so I
do like one last push to get him up on
the school and my back when just really
get any sad and I'm like this is some
circle of life they're like you get to
this your your back goes out then you
fall in the shower and someone has to
help you in there is it just you know
and I'm what cuz the shower we still
going i'm all it was terrible and your
odds at this point yeah yeah and
clothing what is never a good look I so
yeah Bob's dead now so I have that to
look forward this is true but last day
before we are we shared a room last
night because we're a big deal so we get
separate rooms of this back there is a
bummer book [ __ ] we feed the club
because i was talking about i'm going
through [ __ ] with my family and I was
like there's just a pause and I just go
I love you talk
I want you get ahead of that where's
Keith me you need them
thank you for Jim is really giving the
plug I know I host the ufc's podcast UFC
unfiltered it's out twice a week and if
you want to hear us you can find it I
don't have a plug I'm going to end or
other Sunday skaaland oh yeah right Oh
watch The Daily Show please yes and ours
are a regular 1 i'm at shawnee time on
twitter and i have a website i have an
album out called manual labor face yeah
oh you can get two of you'd like to
that's perhaps I to incent and we want
seven at DS Jermaine and watch not safe
with Nikki Glaser I wrote on that so if
you guys enjoy today please look of our
podcast online it's so much fun we have
tools episodes and we really appreciate
you guys coming out give yourselves a
round of applause for your damn it is
yes Thank You Jessica laughs thank you
Sam is that Tom gone yeah he runs our
Twitter for the pumpkins at friends cast
you can just search at you just said
food and blankets to thank you I think
it's amazing that we all actually
believe the ROI goes longer there was a
hooker of my room but my friend
thank you for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast thank you to everybody
who came out to our show in Montreal and
especially everybody who retweeted our
tweets about our show in Montreal and
shared our facebook page and told their
friends you guys are the ones that
helped fill up our room and made our
show such a great one of them one of the
best podcasts at the festival we were
told also thank you to just for laughs
for giving us the opportunity to perform
our podcast live at the most amazing
comedy festival in the world thank you
also to our donors Michael Murphy
Chester hearten Michael maroc thank you
for donating via are safe and secure
paypal link at my dumb friends podcast
tumblr.com you made our show possible as
well here's where you can see our host
performing live this week Sean Donnelly
is performing in and around New York
City you can keep up with him at shawnee
time on Twitter you can also go to Sean
Donnelly comedy calm and get his album
there dan st. germain is performing in
and around Los Angeles before his
upcoming trip to Scottsdale Arizona
where he will be at stand-up Scottsdale
the 18th through the 20th of august but
in the meantime he's all over Los
Angeles go to dan st. germain net and
check out his schedule and we will be
back next week with another great
podcast thank you everybody again for
your support and it was it was a huge
privilege to go up to Montreal and be a
part of the show with Dan and Sean and I
would like to thank them for giving me
that opportunity so hey we'll be back
next week thanks again bye bye
real proud tonight other cool comedy
podcasts go to all things comedy com yes
we're a part of the All Things comedy
network we're one of many great comedy
podcasts that's all things comedy doc
we're gonna work on next week our
opening and closing song is called Mary
the boxer by Phil Pickens you can find
out more about Phil at Phil Pickens com
no I've been through this you can't hold
me
nah
then you come
me
yes you
and
me
you